when you have a resentment against  someone else it's like drinking poison  and waiting for the other person to die  you're harming yourself you're harming  yourself it's actually selfish to  forgive people and the reason we forgive  people forget about but he owes me this  but he did we forgive others not because  they deserve forgiveness but because we  deserve peace it's your job to heal  yourself I know that's that that is my  as soon as I started thinking that way  and as soon as I started saying like why  doesn't someone just invent a time  machine to change my childhood like what  did I think was going to happen you know  I think you get to a point where you're  like I've tried all these things blame  just doesn't work Obsession doesn't work  silently seething doesn't work  complaining all day doesn't work you  know let me just try this whole you know  grant me the serenity accept the things  I cannot change the courage to change  and the wisdom to know the difference